my name is james brock and i work at the
ai consultancy company cross compass in
tokyo this is my talk monadic parser is
at the input boundary for pure cons 2022
i'm a maintainer for the purescript
parsing library and the examples in this
talk will use syntax and type names from
that library this talk is for an
audience who has some familiarity with
regular expressions and monads
a process running on a computer is
isolated from other processes on that
computer and from the rest of the world
on that isolation boundary the process
has input and output the process views
its inputs and outputs as either
discrete events like signals and mouse
clicks or as byte streams the term
bytestream includes any string like
thing like file names web browser form
field values entire files or anything
else represented in process memory as an
array of bytes we want to talk about
byte streams for output a process
serializes byte streams serializing a
byte stream is easy we write a byte
stream and we send it there are no
surprises for input a process
deserializes a byte stream
deserializing a byte stream is hard when
a process reads a byte stream it must
somehow turn the information in the byte
stream into a data structure in the
processes native language reading a byte
stream is difficult because there may be
surprises we expect the byte stream to
have a certain structure but it may not
have that structure a large portion of
process bugs crashes and security
vulnerabilities can be characterized as
a process misbehaving when it encounters
surprises in an input by stream we have
many different terms we use to talk
about deserializing a byte stream
including decoding validating lexing
tokenizing and pattern matching these
different terms describe activities
which are all essentially similar we
will say that all of this means parsing
it is the act of reading and parsing
input byte streams that we will focus on
in this talk we will be talking mostly
about unicode strings but everything in
this talk will generalize to any kind of
byte stream
in the year 2022 here are some common
methods for parsing an input byte stream
write an ad hoc parser based on string
splitting and regular expressions this
is how we end up writing a process which
misbehaves on surprises it's easy to
make mistakes here and forget to handle
certain cases
use a parser generator like google
protocol buffers this works great as
long as the input is in this format but
that is often not true
use json again this obviously only works
if the input is json the reason why such
a huge amount of network traffic these
days is json is exactly because reading
a byte stream is difficult and good days
json parsers already exist for every
language people would rather mangle
their data into json than write a custom
bytestream parser
and lastly monatic parser combinators
i'll try to convince you that monadic
parsing is the best method for parsing
any arbitrary input byte stream and this
is always the first method you should
try when you are reading a byte stream
from over the process input boundary
i'll read to you from the essay parse
don't validate by alexis king consider
what is a parser really a parser is just
a function that consumes less structured
input and produces more structured
output by its very nature a parser is a
partial function some values in the
input do not correspond to any value in
the output so all parsers must have some
notion of failure
under this flexible definition parsers
are an incredibly powerful tool they
allow discharging checks on input up
front right on the boundary between a
program and the
outside world
and once these checks have been
performed they never need to be checked
again haskellers are well aware of this
power
a parser sits on the boundary between
your application and the external world
that world doesn't speak in product in
some types but in streams of bytes so
there's no getting around a need to do
some parsing doing that parsing up front
before acting on the data can go a long
way toward avoiding many classes of bugs
some of which might even be security
vulnerabilities so alexis king is
discussing the abstract idea of what it
means to parse something she does not
talk about monadic parsers or any kind
of monads at all her emphasis is on
taking an unstructured input like a byte
stream and turning it into a data
structure
that data structure should ideally make
illegal states unrepresentable this is a
common proverb in the functional
programming world it's only possible to
do this in programming languages which
have a strong enough type system that
the compiler can check your code for you
and prove that certain things will
always be true and certain variants will
hold if we parse our input byte stream
into a data structure which makes
illegal states unrepresentable then by
producing an instance of the data
structure we have provided a proof that
our input byte stream is in some sense
legal the easiest way to do this is with
monadic parsers
a parsing monad is a monad with three
features it knows its position in the
input string it can choose alternate
parsing branches based on the contents
of the input string and it can fail in
the case that the input string is
illegal and cannot be parsed
there are many implementations of
monadic parser combinators in many
languages and all of them have these
features
these three features are necessary for a
parsing monad and they are also
sufficient any monad which has these
three features is a parsing monad
let's look at an example of matching a
pattern with a monadic parser
here is the same pattern expressed with
a regular expression and with a monadic
parser the pattern which we want to
match is a string that starts with a
lowercase a character and then has
either a lowercase b character or an
uppercase b character
then we also want to capture the b
character whether it was lowercase or
uppercase in the regular expression we
capture the b by surrounding it with
parentheses in the monadic parture
parser we capture the b character by
returning it from the monadic
computation let's look at the monadic
parser computation it's in the form of a
do block on the first line of the do
block we match a literal a character and
then throw it away by binding it to the
underscore variable we don't need to
bind it to a named variable because
after we've matched it then we don't
need it anymore now remember that the
parser monad has state inside of it
which tracks the current position in the
input string the act of successfully
matching the a character will step the
current input string position forward by
one character
on the next line of the do block we
match a lowercase or uppercase b
character and bind it to a variable
named x the way that we say that x can
be either lowercase b or uppercase b is
by using the alternative operator the
alternative operator is kind of like the
or operator which is why we write it as
a bracketed vertical pipe character
the alternative operator is a binary
operator which takes two parsers as
arguments it first tries the left parser
and if that succeeds then it returns the
result if the left parser fails then it
tries the right parser and returns the
result of that so then after this
alternative parser succeeds the x
variable will contain either lowercase b
or uppercase b
then we return the variable x from the
monad
computation now let's modify this parser
slightly so that instead of returning
the captured d character it returns a
data structure let's return a very
simple data structure what is the
simplest data structure it's a single
bit and a single bit contains all the
information we need about whether the b
character was uppercase or lowercase
so now we've changed the type of parser
to return a boolean instead of a care
the parser returns true if the parse
succeeded and the b character was
uppercase
this is an example of what we mean when
we say that we want to return typed data
structures which make illegal states
unrepresentable there are only two
possible ways to successfully parse this
string and the data structure which
we're returning has exactly two possible
values and no more
so
recall that i said that a monadic parser
needs three features the state of the
current position in the input string
alternative and failure let's see what
happens when the a b parser fails we
give it an illegal string a x xx and
instead of returning right and a boolean
data structure it returned left with a
description at a position for the error
the error says that it failed to parse
because it was expecting a b character
at position two
when we're parsing patterns out of a
string a common thing to want to do is
pattern repetition let's try repeating
the a b pattern
we added the asterisk quantifier to the
regular expression to repeat the pattern
many times
we also defined a new parser named a b
many the a b parser uses the many parser
combinator to match the a b pattern many
times
let's talk about what we mean by a
parser combinator a parser combinator is
a normal purescript function it is a
function which takes a parser as an
argument and then returns a new parser
the type of the data structure produced
by the new parser may be different in
this example you can see that the a b
parser has type parser string boolean
because it is a parser from a string to
a boolean we passed the a b parser as an
argument to the many parser combinator
and the mini parser combinator returned
a new parser with type parser string
array boolean
the data structure produced by the new
parser will be an array of booleans
so we run this new a b many parser and
it matches the a b pattern as many times
as it can on the input string and then
returns an array which is true for each
of the matched a b patterns which had an
uppercase b character
parser combinators may take more than
one parser argument for example the
alternative operator which we are using
in the av parser to match either a
lowercase b character or an uppercase b
character is also in fact a parser
combinator
that alternative binary operator is a
function which takes two arguments a
left parser and a right parser it
returns a new parser which tries first
the left parser and then tries the right
parser
so parsers call parser combinators and
pass parsers as arguments the parser
combinators which return new parsers
this is how we build up parsers for
complicated pattern matching let's try
writing our own picture combinator
here is a parser combinator which we
have named twice it is a lot like the
many combinator and in fact it has the
same type signature the difference
between the many combinator and the
twice combinator is that the many
combinator will try to match its
argument parser as many times as
possible but the twice combinator will
match his argument parser exactly two
times no more no less
the twice combinator takes one parser as
an argument which we have named p the p
parser can be any type of parser which
is what we mean by for all a the type
parameter for the p parser is named a
the twice combinator will first try to
match the p parser and bind the result
to the name p1 then it will try to match
the p parser again and bind the result
to the name p2 if both of those succeed
then it will return an array with p1 and
p2
down below we define and run a parser
named av twice with the same input as
before you can see that the a b twice
parser matches the a b pattern two times
and returns true when the matched
pattern has an uppercase b character
so we can see that regular expressions
and monotic parsers both solve
essentially the same pattern matching
problem but the monadic parser is much
longer than the regular expression and
has a lot more code is that bad the
thing about regular expressions is that
they seem like a reasonable and
efficient solution for small toy pro
examples like these
but when we take on larger and more
complex problems the advantage of
monotic parsers becomes apparent and
that's analogous to the situation with
pure functional programming it's
difficult to convey the advantage of
pure functional programming with small
toy examples because small toy programs
are simple in any language the
advantages of pure functional
programming become truly apparent when
we are maintaining and refactoring and
improving large complicated computer
programs
in the same way the advantage of monadic
parsing over regular expressions becomes
apparent when we are parsing more
complicated patterns
let's parse something a little bit
harder how about an email address we all
have a pretty good idea what the format
for an email address is
here is the complete internet
engineering task force specification for
the format of an email address
okay that's a little bit hard it's not
quite as simple as we might have
expected but it's not too bad let's
think about what it says the forward
slashes and the syntax mean alternative
which means either the one on the left
or the one on the right the square
bracket syntax means that something is
optional so it's okay if that thing is
missing
first the specification says that an
address is either a mailbox or a group
then it says that a mailbox is either a
name adder or an adder spec then it says
that a name adder is an optional display
name followed by an angle adder then it
says that an angle adder is an optional
common folding white space followed by a
left angle bracket character followed by
an outer spec followed by a right angle
bracket character followed by an
optional comment folding white space
or alternately it can be an obs angle
adder and it goes on like this
can we write a monadic parser to parse
an email address
here is a monadic parser for parsing
ietf email addresses written by fraser
tweed allen published in the haskell
library purebred email this is in the
haskell language and uses the addo
parsec parsing library the syntax for
purescript using the purescript parsing
library would be almost exactly the same
the monadic parser looks a lot like the
internet engineering task force
specification let's compare the
specification and the monadic parser
line by line
first the spec says that an address is
either a mailbox or a group the monadic
parser says that an address is either a
group or a single mailbox so the order
of the alternative was flipped but
that's fine i'm sure fraser tweedle had
good reasons for doing that
next the spec says that a mailbox is
either a name adder or an adder spec
in the monadic parser i see address spec
on the right side of the alternative and
that expression on the left side must be
equivalent to a name adder i guess
there is an option optional display name
the optional function is a parser
combinator which does exactly what you'd
expect it will try to match the display
name pattern one time but if the display
name pattern is not there then it skips
it
next the spec says that an angle adder
is this adder spec expression surrounded
by angle bracket characters and optional
comment folding white space expressions
or alternately an obs angle adder
the monadic parser says basically the
same thing i don't see the obs angle
adder alternative in the monotic parser
for angle adder maybe we should open an
issue with fraser tweetale and ask him
about this
finally the spec says that a mailbox
list is either a comma separated list of
mailboxes or alternately an obsm box
list
and the monatic parser also says that a
mailbox list is a comma separated list
of mailboxes again the monadic parser
omits the alternative i don't know why
the point is that the formal spec for
rfc
5322 and the mod attic parser
implemented in haskell are very similar
we can see what the monotic parser is
doing and we can ask ourselves
reasonable questions about the
implementation next let's look at the
same rfc 5322 spec implemented as a
regular expression
the author of this regular expression
claims that it quote
99.99 works for parsing rfc 5322 email
addresses
and he may be right about that but how
can we tell
the regular expression for rfc 5322 is
shorter than the monadic parser but it's
very difficult to read it or make
improvements
this is why regular expressions are
included in the pejorative wikipedia
article about write-only programming
languages here's a quote from the
article
write only code is source code so arcane
complex or ill-structured that it cannot
be reliably modified or even
comprehended by anyone with the possible
exception of the author
now email addresses didn't start out as
an internet engineering task force
specification
they were intended to be simple and they
started out simple in the 1970s an email
address was a username and then an at
sign and then the name of a computer we
could parse that with a regular
expression but over time email addresses
became more complicated as everything
does monatic parsers will scale and grow
in a much more maintainable way than
regular expressions and even small
patterns written as a monotic parser
will be easier for others to read
we often use regular expressions to scan
a string and capture all the patterns
which we find here we want to find all
of the integers in the string ten x two
y negative three and split them out
we've done this with both a regular
expression and a monotic parser there
are a couple things to notice here first
the monadic parser for an integer
doesn't just match a string pattern and
return a string it actually converts the
string to an integer and returns the
integer we're using the interdecimal
parser which is included in the
purescript parsing library
the splitcap function runs the int
decimal parser on this string and
produces for us a fully typed data
structure which tells us everything
there is to know about the structure of
the input string with respect to the to
the integer patterns in the string the
second thing to notice is that we made a
mistake when we are writing the integer
pattern for the regular expression we
forgot to think about whether we want to
allow negative integers
now it's easy to change our regular
expression so that it will allow
negative integers and i'm sure you all
know how to do that
what's hard is to take that improved
integer regular expression pattern and
publish it in a library so that other
people can avoid making the same mistake
of course regular expression libraries
do exist and they contain useful
patterns like the email regular regular
expression which we saw before but they
really don't compose very well the only
way to compose regular expressions
together is to concatenate the regular
expression strings this is because again
regular expressions are a whole domain
specific language which is embedded in
some other host language regular
expressions don't have any of the
composition features like functions and
modules that we expect from general
purpose programming languages
monadic parsers on the other hand are
just normal peer script functions and
they compose very well we've seen how to
compose monotic parsers together by
writing parser functions with parser
combinators remember that the term
parser combinator just means a function
which takes some parsers as arguments
and then returns a new parser
there are
many other tricks we can do when we're
using monadic parsers for pattern
matching there's one more trick that i
want to mention in particular and that
is matching recursive patterns
regular expressions famously cannot
parse an input string which has a
recursive or tree-like structure that
means that regular expressions cannot
parse html they cannot parse json they
cannot match balanced parentheses all of
these things have a recursive tree-like
structure
here's a monadic parser named balance
parens which matches a balanced group of
parentheses it will pair each open
parenthesis with a closed parenthesis
and capture the group when the last
parenthesis closes
the way we write a monadic parser to
parse a recursive structure like this is
that we write a recursive monotic parser
you can see that the monadic parser
calls itself on the second line and that
is how it tracks its depth in the
parenthesis parse tree
i'll read to you from the introduction
to the paper parsec direct style monadic
parser combinators for the real world by
dan lyon and eric meyer
parser combinators have always been a
favorite topic amongst functional
programmers burge already described a
set of combinators in 1975
they have been studied extensively over
the years by many others in contrast to
parser generators that offer a fixed set
of combinators to express grammars these
combinators are manipulated as first
class values and can be combined to
define new combinators that fit the
application domain
another advantage is that the programmer
uses only one language avoiding the
integration of different tools and
languages attributed to hughes 1989.
i want to repeat one of the key points
about monadic parsers they are written
in normal purescript parsing input is
such a hard problem that when people
want to do it they traditionally use a
whole domain specific language for
parsing the most famous domain specific
language for parsing is regular
expressions but there are many others
there has been a long tradition of
general purpose languages which are so
weak that it's impossible to write
anything in them which is slightly hard
like parsing an input stream
the whole point of the perl programming
language is that it's a weak comparative
style language with regular expressions
built in so that we can use regular
expressions for parsing input byte
streams that's the whole point of pearl
but it doesn't really solve the problem
in a satisfactory way when our computer
program consists of two different
languages then we have the usual problem
of language interoperation and the usual
solution to language interoperation is
to pass strings a regular expression can
capture a pattern in a string but then
it returns the captured pattern back to
the host language as a string and then
what do we do with the string we still
have to turn the captured string into a
data structure
remember that we looked at the problem
of extracting integers out of some input
string we wrote a regular expression
which found integer looking substrings
and we ran it on the input string the
regular expression found some matches
and returned the captured substrings
suppose we then ran a string to integer
conversion function on a captured
substring and the string to integer
conversion function failed but then was
the captured substring a legal integer
string or wasn't it
in monadic parsers we turn the string
into a data structure in our native
language during the parse so there is no
ambiguity about whether or not the input
string was legal
in this case the data structure is an
integer that's a very simple data
structure but it is a data structure if
we have a thing which is not an integer
then we can't represent it as an integer
so producing an instance of the integer
data structure provides a proof that the
input string was legal
monadic parsers allow us to match
patterns in normal purescript instead of
using a domain-specific parsing language
like regular expressions and after we
have matched a pattern we produce a data
structure which preserves the proof that
the input string was legal
here is a type for a monadic parser this
is an excerpt from the 1998 paper
functional pearls monadic parsing and
haskell by graham hutton and eric meyer
on the bottom line it says that the type
of a parser for a data type a is a
function from a string to a list of
pairs of an a and a string
this simple type definition tells us
pretty much everything we need to know
about monadic parsers after we spend
some time thinking about it like all
good math it has a simple definition but
complicated and far-reaching
implications modern monadic parser
libraries usually don't use this exact
type definition for a parser but they
use definitions which are equivalent
the essay revisiting monadic parsing and
haskell by pv by vivab segar has some
good discussion about that
and if that last definition was too
prosaic for you then here is the same
definition expressed as a poem by fritz
rohrer
dr zeus on parser monadz a parser for
things is a function from strings to
lists of pairs of things and strings
okay that's enough theory we'll stop at
the dr zeus level of parsing theory we
don't actually need to know any theory
to use monadic parsers but now you know
that the theory exists and that the
theory and techniques have been pretty
well established since the 1990s
so
in a javascript runtime environment you
can expect a purescript monatic parser
to run at least 10 times slower than a
javascript regular expression that's
just how it is and that situation
probably will not improve much in the
future if your input byte stream will be
large and you need to process it quickly
then you might not be able to use
purescript monotic parsers
but all of the techniques we talked
about here are also used in haskell
there are haskell monatic parsing
libraries such as atoparsac which run
very fast about as fast as regular
expressions sometimes faster
so if you learn these monatic parsing
techniques then you can apply them in
other execution environments very well
whenever your process receives a byte
stream from the world beyond the process
input boundary the first thing you
should do is to parse that byte stream
into a data structure monadic parsers
are the easiest and most effective way
to do that unless you already have a
parsing library for the specific format
of the byte stream or you are under
severe performance constraints the first
technique you should consider for
parsing an input byte stream is monadic
parsers thank you very much for
listening to my talk oh
uh here's a question from toastall
has the performance of the of the part
have the performance of the parsers in
purescript improved recently i tried to
use a lib from csv but it crashed my
browser because of purescripts parser
being slow
no they haven't really improved and it's
hard to improve them i've been working
on that uh i've tried some different
things it's difficult there are actually
two monadic parsing libraries in
purescript there's pure script parsing
which is which is i'm the maintainer of
and which i've been talking mostly about
today there's also another one called
purestrip string parsers the main
difference with purescript string
parsers is that it does not use
monad transformers which is which makes
it faster
and so if you have uh if you have
performance problems you can try using
that one it will run a little bit faster
but really regular expressions in a
javascript execution environment are
just going to be faster
uh because there's a whole there's a
whole you know just-in-time regular
expression compiler that compiles
regular expressions in javascript down
to very fast code and runs them
and and we don't have there's no
equivalent jit compiler from monadic
parsers
so
in general
monadic parsers don't have to be slower
than regular expressions they just they
are for historical reasons because
uh you know google and the webkit
developers have spent just thousands you
know years and years of programmer time
and millions of dollars in programmer
salaries optimizing regular expressions
and and regular expressions in and other
libraries have been optimized for
decades and decades and as well and
they're they're super fast now monadic
parsers can be fast in many cases they
are fast the atto parsec library is fast
it is like i said in the talk it's can
be as fast or faster than regular
expressions in javascript runtime
environment that's not that situation is
not going to get better anytime soon
okay so let's go to another question um
so james collier asks can monadic
parsers also parse non-regular languages
like context-sensitive grammars yes
really good question i want to talk
about that uh let me let me ask let me
answer james's other question first so
his question so his other question is
recursive monadic parsing isn't
complicated by strict evaluation it is
not it is not it's not complicated by
strict evaluation that's a really good
question though it's a very very good
thing to ask especially when you're
coming from haskell into purescript
sometimes you get bitten by strict
evaluation but in general no it's going
to be fine the place where it would
really bite you is with the alternative
operator
uh if it were going to you know if you
don't want your you don't want because
alternative operator is a function and
purescript is strict in evaluating its
in for functions which means it will
fully evaluate all the arguments before
it calls the function and so if you have
an alternative operator which fully
evaluated the left parser and fully
voted the right picture and then you
know called the function like wouldn't
that mean that both parsers get
evaluated well no it doesn't because it
fully evaluates the parser but it
doesn't run the parser so all the
semantics of of monadic parsing and
purescript work exactly how you would
expect them to work if you're coming
from a lazy language like haskell and
and haskell monadic parser libraries
uh
another question
uh
oh oh your other question was can
monadic parsers also parse non-regular
languages like context-sensitive
grammars
so
let me get back to that in just a second
let me see what other questions there
are
in raku you can have recursive regex
patterns yes and oh yeah right sir and
that's an extension but it's an
extension that makes the regex parser
not regular so like
you're getting none of the advantages
like
you you're getting you're losing a lot
of the advantages of regular expressions
that they can be
equivalent to a um
a um
a finite state automata but you then
you're getting but you're getting the
disadvantages of regular expressions
which is the syntax so like yeah you
kind of get
worst of both worlds with writ with
recursive regular regular expressions
grammars are interesting too and raku
that's cool thanks for the link i i'm
not familiar with
raku does that mean we can mix in regex
for speed yes yes you can mix in regex
for speed especially the purescript
string parsers library in purescript
uh
has a regex parser and i have an issue
on pure script parsing because i want to
add a regex parser into pure script
parsing so you can call regex in the
middle of a monadic parser it's a really
good feature you can do that in
purescript string parsing you'll be able
to do it in pure script parsing very
soon what about a monadic parser
commentator library that compiles to
regex
from joseph young
ah
that is
so there's a haskell library which is
called
uh applicative regex
no regex applicative it's called regex
applicative it is super super
interesting uh i can't remember the name
of the author off the top of my head but
basically what it is is it's a
regular expression library but it's
written in terms of applicative
combinators in haskell
so
it's not monadic instead it's
applicative applicative is a slightly
weaker
algebraic structure which is kind of
like a monad but
in applicative computations you know the
shape of the computation in advance as
you do with regular expressions so you
you actually don't need a full monad if
you're just doing regular grammars you
can use an applicative and that's what
the regex applicative is all about and
that library is very very interesting
you've got all the nice syntax and
composability
of monadic parse of a monarch parsing
library but you get uh it parses regular
grammars
why do all parsers have that bite to
so t-rex why do all parsers have that
bite to tuple type
because
i'm not sure what you mean by that a lot
of the a lot of the examples i used in
the talk where the care parser
uh which takes which which parses one
byte
could you ask could you rephrase that
question please i'm not sure you mean by
that
severe performance constraints yeah okay
i talked about that
um
so
okay i want to talk about i want to go
back to james collier's other question
about uh
if
a monadic parsing comparison not can
parse a context-sensitive grammar what
does he mean by that he's talking about
oh let me share my screen here
can you see this am i sharing yes this
is showing okay he's talking about
really what he's talking about is this
the chomsky hierarchy everybody here
familiar with
gnome
[Music]
chomsky
this guy he's super famous
and this is what he is famous for the
chomsky hierarchy
provides a hierarchy of
grammar complexity
and regular expressions can parse yes
noam chomsky regular expressions can
parse regular languages which are type
three
the weakest level on the chomsky
hierarchy
um
monadic parsers because can can parse
the next level up type two context-free
grammars
um
because
they can be because they're normal
functions
they can be recursive they can call
themselves like any normal function in
pure script and because they're
recursive
then you then they are effectively the
same as a non-deterministic push down
automaton a push down automaton is just
another name for the data structure
known as a stack where you can push
things and then pop things and your your
call stack becomes the data structure
which
provides the push down automaton
capability and then you get type 2 so
you can parse type 2 context-free
grammars
now there's a way to get to type 1 with
monadic parsers 2. and that is through
monad transformers which is what um
which is what um which is what jordan's
talk was about
if you have a parsing library i didn't
talk about this during the talk but um
all the parser types in pure script
parsing are monad transformers and um
you can you can add which means you can
add new monad capabilities to your
parsing monad and you can which means
you can bring in any context into the
computation that you want any kind of
monadic capability like a statement ad
you can you can transform your parser on
ad with a statement ad and then you can
bring in some state context into your
computation and then you can use that
context that you brought in to make
decisions about your parsing and that
makes your parsing context sensitive and
then you can parse type 1 grammars
using monadic parser combinators type 1
grammars include
most computer programming languages for
instance so if you want to parse a
computer programming language you will
need a parser that can parse type one
grammars and monadic parser combinators
with monad transformers can do that
um
any other questions oh
t-rex question type parser a string
equal string a parser is a function from
strings to lists of pairs of strings and
things you said this always holds true
and is proven why is it true
uh it's true
it's not it's not exactly a theorem it's
a type and so that
if you have uh
so this type
it's um
if this type if you have a if you have a
a parser which has this type then
that'll then it gives you all the
capabilities that you need for a parsing
monad it gives you
it gives you alternative failure and uh
parsing state so that's why that's a
parsing monad and like i said during the
talk
that's not actually the exact type which
is used in
um
which is used in pure skirt parsing but
it's it uses a type which is equivalent
and um the best discussion of this is
vibhub segar's essay revisiting monadic
parsing and haskell it's a really good
discussion of for this question
um
aditya says for a moment i was wondering
when noam chomsky became a mathematician
yeah he is he kind of is a mathematician
he's the reason he's so famous the
reason he's the most cited scholar
living alive today and the most famous
you know public intellectual in america
is because he brought
this mathematics this mathematics of um
of um
of computational logic into the field of
linguistics and applied it and began
answering questions which no one had
ever been able to come up with good
answers before before
um
noam chomsky actually thinks that the
difference between humans and animals is
that
human brains
uh
are capable of
are essentially touring machines that
they
that they have a grammar generation
organ
which um is subject to the fundamental
theorem of computer science
that um
which is you know and that's that's
that's really what known chomsky is all
about that's why he's super famous
uh
yeah you should go down to wikipedia
rabbit hall about that it's super
interesting
uh
let me let me let me show you some stuff
here
so
let me show you an example of what it
looks like to pull in context actually i
don't know maybe at my maybe my question
and answer session is
going over here i'd you tell me if i if
you want to go to the next talk okay
um
so
this is uh
so this is from the documentation for my
uh
my haskell megaparsec version of the
replace the parsing replace library this
replace library is a library that i've
written three times and i alluded to to
it in the talk it's not part of the
basic
parsing library
it's not part of the basic monadic
parsing library it's an it's an add-on
library which provides some extra
features i basically wrote this library
by going through
[Music]
the python
re module which is really good and has
it's about regular expressions and
provides all the features that you can
do for regular expressions in python and
it's really ergonomic and really useful
and
and so i just went through this whole
library and made sure that everything
you can do with regular expressions in
python you can also do with haskell or
purescript every time i found something
that you couldn't do then i added it to
uh this family of libraries that i wrote
and um and published it there's there's
three of them there's purescript parsing
replace and then there's also haskell
libraries uh replace megaparsec and
replace ado parsec for those parsing
libraries
and so from the right replace megaparsec
library this shows you how you can pull
in
a state context into a monadic parsing
operation
in order to provide in order to parse
context-sensitive grammars in order you
know solve context-sensitive parsing
problems
um and here and as you maybe remember
from jordan's talk you apply a
monad transformer and you pull in a
state
and then you just uh stack your parsing
your you use that as a basemon ad for
your parsing monad and then you have the
state available to you while you're
doing the parsing computation and this
is this allows you to solve this allows
you to do the same thing that you would
in parsing
re sub
n so in in python resub n it performs
the same operation as sub n returns a
tuple which tells you the number of
substitutions that you made so let's
what is sub then sub
uh
is is search and replace it searches
through a string replaces everything but
you can also tell it to stop after a
little while and you can you can say you
only want to do a certain number of
substitutions and stop after that and
then report back after
uh you've made the substitutions and in
python they had to provide a whole
function in the library which is this
resub function or actually the re sub n
function
but in
but with these monotic parsing libraries
with with monad transformers we don't
need to provide a library function we
don't need to add anything to the api
this is just an example which shows you
how to do it
because part monad parser transformers
already give you all
the power that you all the capabilities
you need to do an operation like that uh
you just have to it but it helps to see
an example it's hard to figure it out if
you've never done it before so there's
an example of that provided
in replacement parsec and there's also
an example on the
purescript um
in the purescript parsing replace
library
so i think i'm going to stop there
that's all i have to say did i miss any
questions while i was talking oh how
easy is it how easy is it to parse
binary data in purescript great question
super easy super easy on the pure script
parsing library go down here
related packages pure script parsing
data view if you want to parse
binary array buffers you can use this
library here which goes with pure script
parsing
um okay before we move on um just uh
there's actually a question that james
uh that i think anupam you're gonna have
to take this question uh james collier
was asking regarding jordan stock
and
uh one second
uh yes uh james collier was asking on
youtube regarding jordan's talk um is
the stately transformer related to the
st monad
is the state t mona transformer related
to the st monad
oh that's sorry that's a monadic uh
transformer talk jordan do you want to
take that one
you can take that one too
okay uh no it's different that's
confusing because uh they sound the same
but they're different monads st monad is
like an effect monad for when you just
want to have some local effects and do
some mutation st monad is basically a
performance trick that you can do if you
have an algorithm you want to do for um
for and you want to do some local
mutation in a little localized area like
an isolated localized area in your
program where you do mutation and then
you get the result out of that that's
what the st monad is for and then the
state team on ad is a monad transformer
for carrying state along in a monadic
computation